offensively but much better here in the  fourth quarter kind of turning the  faucet off on Charlotte a little bit  somebody lost a shoe and it's lamb  because inspired the shoe is going to  get a technical foul  and there's the rule and then there's  the spirit of the rule he threw the shoe  so no one would trip on it or hurt  themselves but you can't throw anything  into the crowd what you have here is  subjective waiting this is all  subjective did he know whose shoe it was  did he throw it on purpose  Oh further away  [Music]  and that's an official just made a  judgement about that I said there's the  rule and then the spirit of the rule  there's a shoe right to free-throw line  he tosses it away he's not doing it in  anger or frustration writers are hurt  anybody's right the front wall that that  now that is when the league should  rescind that should not be a technical  [Music]  [Applause]